okay thank you so much for the
invitation and like I said I'm between
you and your lunch so since I'm in the
front here you can get up and get your
lunch at any point in time I'm sure I'm
not going to worry too much about that
so the the two talks before me are great
introductions or lead into what I'm
going to say there's there's a was going
to be a healthy discussion after this
I'm sure in terms of what we're what
we're getting into and and so I was
given the topic of observational
constraints on modern climate
sensitivity and I think that gets into
the climate sensitivity that we're
talking about for the last century and
so this idea of long-term climate
sensitivity on millennial time scale or
back the climate sensitivity associated
with paleo climate events is something
that is a major interest to us in terms
of what's going to happen a thousand
years and so on but the data that we
actually have is for the last hundred
150 years that's of sufficient quality
to make us think about the patterns of
climate change and the the changes that
we have that are going to be affecting
us over the next fifty to a hundred
years and so that's what we're dealing
with so the 32 the other problem is that
when you give a talk like this you put
your slides together and you find out
that everybody else has used all your
slides so it's almost better at the end
of the day just to stand up and talk
instead of working from your slides so I
thought it would be worth a little bit
to say one is how are we actually
estimating the equilibrium climate
sensitivity and and I think that this is
a just a laser pointer yeah so the so I
say our goal here is is that we're
trying to match a parameter in a model
or the model response to the record of
the 20th century and or you're looking
at some climate change in the past and
the historical past or the paleoclimate
past and trying trying to do the same
thing and so you
in one sense the real issue here is is
what is the model and if you're a full
full atmosphere ocean GCM or full Earth
system model or what you're probably
interested in is this one here the earth
system models and you have a huge number
of parameters associated with the
parameterizations and that's what Dan
was referring to at the beginning of his
talk and the problem is is that you
can't tune or calibrate every one of
those model those model parameters to
the 20th century record so what you wind
up doing is looking at the model
response over the past hundred years and
then scaling that response to estimate
what the climate sensitivity is as a
result of this and so you can do that
with individual model simulations or you
can do that with an ensemble of
simulations and that's one approach to
trying to estimate what climate
sensitivity is from the state-of-the-art
climate models as a result there's
another spot in here well down at the
bottom here I have the the other
approach which i think is sort of what
Steve was discussing in his talk which
is using essentially a very simplified
energy balance model for the planet and
to all intents and purposes you have to
you have to satisfy that energy balance
for the planet and I think that's one of
the take-home points of his talk and I
completely agree with that the question
is how do you go about doing that and
then what do you how do you interpret
the climate sensitivity of that from
that estimate as a result for the energy
balance models that can be an
equilibrium parameter it's just a single
parameter lambda which was in was in
that model there are more comprehensive
energy balance models the magic model is
a classic one it has two hemispheric
temperature boxes and you have a single
parameter lambda and that in that in
that system but you're resolving a
little bit more of the system the other
approach is to hit in this sort of sweet
spot in between with earth system models
of intermediate complexity and this is
the area where I've worked in for most
of my my work on this and the parameters
that you're calibrating or estimating
from the
procedure are not strictly climate
sensitivity what you're calibrating our
processes which control the feedbacks
within the system and so cloud feedback
is an uncertainty in the climate models
that was alluded to and so can you can
you calibrate the cloud feedback in the
model and then infer what climate
sensitivity is from that after after the
fact and so part of the discussion is as
we go through this hierarchy of climate
models what is the one that we want
which ones are the ones that we're going
to be using and trusting and the ones
that are most relevant than for the
economic discussed the economic modeling
and damages questions that are I think
relevant over on so that's my five
minutes I'm done well so I guess that
the other issue here is we have a set of
observations for the 20th century and
how are we going to actually use these
this is a slide I pulled out from I've
shown this a lot a lot of times over the
past decade probably but our goal here
is we're trying to parameterize or sorry
calibrate or estimate these internal
parameters within our emic in this case
and we think of them as climate
sensitivity in an effective ocean
diffusivity and the net aerosol forcing
which we were talking about but we're
trying to calibrate given our
observations and our observations that
we have are a record of air temperature
upper air temperature surface air
temperature SSTs and we also have
observations of the ocean heat content
and those are going into these these
various estimates the big kicker here is
what do we do about the noise covariance
or the variability of the system that
you're using to test your put into your
likelihood function which is then
driving the your ultimate estimate of
the probability distributions for these
for these various parameters so the
method sort of goes like this and in it
this is sort of this is essentially true
for all the three methods that I showed
previously you simulate the 20th century
using anthropogenic and natural forcings
you'd very the values of these
parameters in your model you then
hair the individual model responses
against the observed temperature changes
in what I use is an optimal fingerprint
detection algorithm and that requires an
estimate of the climate variability in
the system as estimated by this noise
covariance matrix then you take that
goodness-of-fit statistic how well is
your model able to reproduce the the
history the historical record and create
a likelihood function and that
likelihood function is estimated for the
different Diagnostics that you're using
the surface temperature ocean
temperature upper air temperatures so on
and so forth and then that finally goes
into a into bayes's theorem and then
you're combining those likelihood
functions with a prior in order to come
up with a probability distribution at
the end of all of this so who is this I
don't know if this is something
everybody knows but it's something that
I think is worth going over for how that
how it sort of plays itself out in the
in the system here so that now I'm
shifting gears a lot and so I was a IPCC
author on the chapter 9 which is the
model evaluation chapter and Dan was
showing some results from that with the
point the the 20th century climate
change for the global mean surface
temperature and for me when I was as
part of the process one of the key
things for me was how are we doing with
the feedbacks in the system not
necessarily looking at the global mean
temperature in the system and this is
where I think this figure is is one of
the big figures that makes us think now
about the the ability for us to model
the sea ice distributions which is one
of the major feedbacks to the Earth's
climate the Earth's albedo and so what
we see here now is the sea ice extent in
the northern hemisphere at the period in
which you have the minimum sea ice
extent for the entire for the for the
summer the Northern Hemisphere summer
and what you a few things that are
obvious here one is the the range of sea
ice extent sort of for the the basic
state here before we even get into the
rapid climate change of the last half of
the century is actually quite large and
and so that means that the baseline from
which you
starting your your your CC o to
experiment is going to be affected by
what that that initial value is for the
for the Earth's albedo then we get out
here to the end and starting in the
1970s when we actually have satellite
observations to track what was happening
that's when we start to see whether or
not we're getting the right rate of
change and the distinction between a
rate of change of something and the
actual change itself or the integrated
change is what matters the integration
of this over time is telling us what the
the the total reflected energy is or the
lack the the the the total absorbed
energy is in that in the northern
hemisphere system that's that's wouldn't
have been there if the ice had melted
that's very different than saying what's
just the actual value of the ice its
extent itself so there's sort of a for
The Economist it's sort of a what is it
a rate and a stock problem in terms of
the way you think about these things
energy is a stock radiative forcing is a
is a rate rate to reflects a flux
quantity so are we getting them are the
models getting it right well here in the
last part of the century you see the the
multi-model mean was was discussed as
being a as being sort of the the best
model and there's a lot of details as to
whether that's you know whether whether
we should believe that or not there are
clearly models that are in here that are
getting the right rate and that's one of
the take-home messages is that there are
good models that are doing this right
not all models are good based on a
single a single metric like the sea ice
extent that we have here so the other
one on the bottom here is the Antarctic
sea ice in February again that's the
time at which the minimum sea ice extent
is occurring in the southern hemisphere
during the summer time and what we have
here is an even larger range of sea ice
extent values and so our uncertainty in
what's happening in the polar regions
now becomes much much much more
important the other the other figure
here was
are you getting the ice in the right
locations the winds and the in the polar
regions are driving and moving the ice
around in those areas and therefore are
controlling essentially whether the ice
is being pushed up against the
continents and remaining in place and
lasting a few years or whether or not
it's it's a it's melting and being
pushed around Greenland and then coming
into the North Atlantic and so you wind
up with less ice in the northern koshin
than you had previously and again the
models are kind of in capturing
encapsulating the the best guess as to
what's going on over the past 20 years
but the range of the range of the models
at reproducing this is quite wider than
I think we would like it to be and so
can we use that as a tool for analyzing
the the ice albedo feedback or the ocean
ice interactions and various other
feedbacks in the system as a result of
this the other the other issues i'm
going to how much time do I really have
five minutes yeah I had five minutes
five minutes ago okay all right so a few
things here one is the goal of what
we're doing is is really trying to match
this global mean temperature record that
we have here many of us use instead of
using the annual data we use a decade
old average or a smooth data set and
that's what's shown down here in the
bottom and the the gray bands here are
actually the estimates and the
observational uncertainty and so one of
my points is that observational
uncertainty is much larger than we had
thought it was probably five to ten
years ago and and so that's coming into
play the other issue on this graph is
the spatial extent of how well we know
the record over the past hundred years
this starts in 1901 and ends in 2012 and
this is the estimated trend over that
time frame so imagine fitting a straight
line to this curve over here and then
plotting that on this over here as a
function of space and a couple of things
one we we have a clear amplification
effect
to going on over land and in the
northern hemisphere we also have less
data down in the Southern Ocean in order
to estimate what the trends were at that
time frame and we also have some holes
in our data set in the tropics and some
areas where we have what are clearly
something's going on there in the in the
North Atlantic which led to cooling over
that time over this hundred and twelve
year period now is it truly a cooling
overall or is it a large fluctuation
that's occurring there and so a trend
isn't necessarily capturing the
variability that we see here in the
global mean temperature record as a
result okay the other big take-home
point is the energy content for the
planet and we've all sort of danced
around this a little bit steve was much
more eloquent maybe about this than I am
but the issue here is we now have an
estimate of the observed heat content
change for the ocean starting in about
the 1970 and ending in 2012 or 2011 here
and that the the picture is so obvious
when you look at it this way that over
ninety percent of the energy content is
going into the ocean and less than less
than ten percent is going into land and
the atmosphere and that means that if
we're going to start actually asking
which observations are most important
for trying to constrain long term the
long term integrated energy content then
we have to ask are we really getting the
oceans right are we getting the mixing
in the oceans correct or not and despite
what's happening at the surface with the
uncertainty in the forcing and the
uncertainty in the clouds and the
aerosols response if it's not going into
the ocean at the right rate then we're
missing something in a significant way i
always like talking about zetas jewels
since nobody knows what is that a jewel
is unless you actually write it out ok
so the radiative forcing picture here
from the IPCC I what I liked in Steve's
talk is that he showed that the estimate
was previously 1.7 or so for the change
in the radiative forcing over the last
100 since 1750
and this is one of the issues that gets
to climate sensitivity I'll skip over
everything else on here but 2.6 just to
remind everybody that's the RCP 2.6
scenario we're only three tenths of a
lot away from that and that's what we're
saying is what we should be stabilizing
at if we're going to be stay with
underneath 2 degrees C so good luck with
that that's to the next generations
who's going to be dealing with this of
course okay radiative forcing and its
uncertainty is a big deal as to why this
there's this big range of well partly
why the equilibrium climate sensitivity
got shifted and it wasn't properly
described or properly the uncertainty in
this term gets thrown around a lot the
issue with the radiative forcing the
effective radiative forcing for cloud
adjustments to aerosols is the language
which is now used in the IPCC it's no
longer the direct effect or the indirect
effect or the semi indirect effect or
the semi direct effect or any of those
which are all in the literature the idea
is is that you have these rapid
adjustments to cloud environment and and
and and so the result of that is all of
these terms here are now incorporated
into a single estimate the change in the
radiative forcing that as you saw was
much weaker in terms of the cooling
effect to the aerosols than it was
previously that leads to a larger
radiative forcing over the 20th century
the same thing though as you saw I was
true for the estimate for the greenhouse
gas forcings we went from I think the
number was 2.9 for the green 2.8 for the
AR for to 3.3 for the ar5 was the
numbers that you showed in your your
talk and therefore the radiative forcing
now has been increased from the total
I'll go back to my little note here the
total number went from 1.6 to 2.3 that
in and of itself is a reason that the
climate sensitivity what one minute so
that in and of itself is a reason that
the climate sensitivity was was was
decreased and part of the reason is
what is leading to us to sort of start
to question where is the inconsistent
between inconsistency between the
climate models and what we're getting
out of these these transient well from
these these other these other estimates
let's see that's all that somebody else
can talk about that later the one thing
this is the result from auto at all
which tried to summarize in another in a
very similar way to what Steve said
which is taking equilibrium climate
sensitivity as a simple linear algebra
problem and I have my issues with that
and we can talk about this later and one
of the reasons for that is because of
what I've done with a simple model I
have one minute Klaus so sorry so I took
a I took one of our MIT I gsm runs and
and so that's the integrated global
systems model the climate model
component component and we ran it with a
climate sensitivity which is set by the
change in the cloud feedback it has a
significant amount of internal
variability so it looks very much like
the real world we also set so we set the
climate sensitivity to be three degrees
we set the aerosol forcing to be alpha
equals 1.7 so that that matches I can I
can and I can then we can then go and
ask what is the running through one of
these Monte Carlo Markov chain model
estimation procedures we get a cloud of
points as to where the values are that
best match that record of observations
so this is a pseudo observations problem
a perfect model experiment the plus up
here is where the model should be at
three degrees it's down here at 1.6 this
estimation procedure is failing for some
reason at being able to reproduce what
the climate model is telling us it
should be this is a serious you know
look into whether or not our procedure
is capable of doing what we expect over
here this is climate sensitivity on this
axis the alpha parameter here and that's
actually the point where it
beginning we're getting a value of 1.6
an alpha scaling of 3.2 and what the
question is what's missing well one of
the issue is global information the
global pictures is not enough I know I
have less than one minute left and and
so climate sensitivity here if I take
just global information and take all of
these other observational uncertainties
include it I get this value up here if I
take hemispheric data climate
sensitivity start starts to shift to a
higher value if i use zonal data which
includes the difference between the pole
and the equator in this polar
amplification of factor i wind up down
in this this picture here and and so in
the aerosol forcing estimate from these
inverse methods is giving us a very wide
range of the aerosol forcing for the
global case it starts to tighten up
until we get down to the case for where
we include the the hemispheric or
spatially resolved information as a
function of latitude so this is starting
to tell us that you know there is data
there that we can use to estimate
climate sensitivity and the aerosol
forcing and so on and so forth are we
using it well I think by thinking about
it from a global mean perspective or not
I think we have to be going to these
higher order methods and the statistics
are funky they need some you know a
decent statistician to help us out as we
as Klaus and I both know working on some
of these things with our friends at at
Penn State but that's that's part of the
picture and then the last one here is
we've taken the observational
uncertainty in the had kruti for data
set hundred different simulations they
created an ensemble which are all
plausible real reconstructions of what
happened over the past century and I ran
our distribution are our calibration
tool with those hundred different cases
and these are now the the spread of the
distribution there's a hundred curves on
there and that now is sort of the
estimated uncertainty one in what the
peak value or the mode is is almost a
difference maybe a full degree there the
air assault
forcing is still in a fairly tightly
coupled but we still have this long tail
it's and it shifts along and this is
just one other example of where these
uncertainties are starting to show up
and I apologize for keeping you hungry
then I'll stop there